so next up you want to Target the poor
here's the thing the average funeral
costs seven thousand dollars even a
simple cremation can cost a thousand
dollars when I'm dead just throw me in
the trash people in poverty can't afford
that so why not offer them a cheaper
more dignified alternative donate your
loved one's body to science and we'll
even pay for the cremation for you that
way instead of having to pay a few racks
it won't cost you a sense and you'll be
sleeping easy knowing that your family
member's body is being used for
something great and guess what nine
times out of ten they always say yes
after all you are getting these poor
families at their worst at their most
vulnerable what kind of a son or
daughter isn't gonna give their parent a
proper goodbye every year more than 20
000 people donate their bodies to
science either because they think it
will make a difference or because they
can't afford the alternatives